one you barely need one but i'll give it
anyway if you don't mind
hey hey hey hey hey hey sam how come i
needed one but russell doesn't
oh you didn't need it either
i'm gonna shut up here in just a second
okay so anyway let's see
so what should i say russell um he
earned his phd at berkeley
he was a postdoc at toronto he's
subsequently been at uc
san diego uh pretty much all the time
there was a five-year stint at the
institute for vance studies
um he's been a guggenheim fellow and a
simon's investigator
he received the inaugural uh
new surprise in 2013.
uh he's well known for many important
contributions in pseudo-randomness
ex-dilemmas
and of course proof proof complexity
among other areas
and he's also a developer of the eth
and strong eth which i suspect we'll
hear something about in this upcoming
talk
which is hypotheses about satisfiability
and their consequences
so russell okay thanks um
so yes today today i am going to talk
mainly about uh the exponential time
hypothesis
and strongly exponential strong
exponential time hypothesis
both of these were joint work with mohan
patturi
uh at ucsd um and um
a bunch of other people were involved so
i'm going to thank mohan
mohan was involved in everything so i'm
going to thank mohan in advance
and try to acknowledge other people as
they come up in the story
so if there's a p that's left as an
initial
that stands for maturity if there's an
eye it stands for me
okay um so um
right so um so cook's theorem
says that uh np complete problems and
satisfiability is like the
the paradigmatic and v complete problem
are the hardest problems in np except it
really doesn't say that
uh because when you when you look at
things
um i seem to be echoing
exactly okay now okay uh
if you look at things quantitatively
different np complete problems
you know if one np np-complete problem
is is
has a great algorithm then the others
have great algorithms
but if you look at their exact time of
the the best known algorithms these are
all over the map
okay they're all exponential but
the uh but the different but they're
different exponential functions and
in exponential and different quantities
okay
so um and if you look at like uh
you know average case time rather than
worst case time or approximation
algorithms or heuristics
they're all really very different as far
as
uh these things are concerned at least
as far as we know
so um so why did i start thinking about
satisfiability
um so you know you know
i'm in complexity theory so you know
thinking about np completeness
is very natural but um when i was
co-teaching a course this is with steve
cook i presented this at a workshop
in honor of steve cook so i didn't have
to say which steve i was talking about
um one topic of the course
was kind of like a robustness of the
linear time hierarchy i don't need to
to really like define what the linear
time hierarchy is
but the idea was that
uh even though linear time is
not uh so well-defined if you look at
like
non-deterministic variants you know
because it depends on the exact model
things like non-deterministic linear
time or much more well-defined
i said well let's at least like you know
we can't prove
p not equal to np we can't even prove np
is different from
exponential time let's at least like
prove that there's some kind of
non-trivial separation of classes
and thinking about this kind of like
non-deterministic linear time said
well that's kind of robust class let's
at least
show that non-terministic time linear
isn't equal to deterministic time
exponential
there you know that's ridiculous to
think that every
exponential time computable problem
would have a linear time certificate
linear size certificate
so um especially one that's not
verifiable in linear time
so when you like look at what uh
almost complete problems for a linear
time uh for non-domestic linear time
you know sat is pretty much complete for
a non-terministic time there's like a
log
factor overhead um so if you can just
give a 2 to the n over login algorithm
for
sat that's still exponential right
that wouldn't be a big deal as far as
like np completeness goes
but it would show that uh
non-deterministic linear time
is strictly contained in deterministic
exponential time
so i'll just find and you know it won't
be the world's most revolutionary
algorithm but from complexity point of
view it would be a pretty big deal to
have a sad algorithm
that ran in time two to the end of our
login
sorry russell are you are you do you
want to put np
in d time to the order n uh
what you wrote there is known
is this is meant to be like strict
subset
string subset of ic so it's known that
it's contained in
but not known that the equal inequality
is the containment is strict
so as far as we know every problem in e
could be in non-terministic linear time
now you have to you have to say okay
so maybe that's not true if you're
restricted to like kk turing machine
i wanted it would be more robust notion
of linear time
so i guess there was
does that answer your question yeah i
just didn't realize that meant proper
containment that's all
okay yeah so the the point is the yes
the the containment is trivial
is the properness you know i couldn't
get
uh i couldn't get um
powerpoint to put a little line through
uh something below the the containment
so um okay so
so what i mean here is proper
containment because it doesn't have a
little line underneath it
okay so uh anyway to do this
all i have to do is come up with a
set algorithm that works a bit better
than
exponential and surely there's such an
algorithm
right um you know and
also said well you don't have to
actually show it
in the worst case per set if you look at
like
you know if we could just show
non-terministic
uh time 2 to the n is contained
strictly contained in deterministic time
2 to the 2 to the order n
you know then that would be enough
actually 2 to the order 2 to the n
that would be enough so you could
actually like look at
some very structured instances of sat
and come up with better algorithms for
that
and actually i don't have a reason why
you couldn't do you couldn't carry that
out for the structured instances of that
so anyway so i went around asking people
like tony potassi
about um you know whether they thought
uh there were better or sad algorithms
and she pointed me to uh
bart selman who was a phd student in the
in the department in toronto uh
who was actually really interested in
better set algorithms
because he was not just uh he
was in the ai group and he was actually
using
sat algorithms to solve real world
problems
a little bit ahead of his time on this
and so he was coming up with positive
approaches to sat solving
that were provably fast in the worst
case but
seem to be working on a lot of
interesting uh
sat problems and there was and so i
became kind of aware
that there was a community developing of
people who were
using sat um
algorithmically and improving the time
for sat algorithms on real world
examples
instances that came from different
applications
and in fact bart was actually really
interested in the theory
of sad algorithms he had a big binder
of um of sat and
other algorithms for sat and other mp
complete problems
and i kind of looking through i was able
to borrow
bart's binder and looking through
there were a lot of really clever ideas
that a lot of very smart people had come
up
in uh improving the algorithms for these
problems already
and they were all really good ideas but
they were all still
kind of exponential time algorithms none
of them uh
you know were suitable for separating
these complexity classes
but and sort of like said you know to
get a better
algorithm in this direction i have to
kind of like be a little clever
than all these very clever people and
the reason why i'm mentioning bart's
binder
because maybe bart will you know still
interested in this area
and maybe he's listening so far
if you want your binder back send me
email
because i still have it okay
so um okay
um so
i was still optimistic about finding
sub-exponential algorithms
for one of these natural np complete
problems so i like
filled up over the the next few years i
filled up a lot of notebooks with
different failed attempts to beat the
known algorithms
and uh you know it was kind of like my
my go-to problem when i couldn't think
of anything else to work on
because it was kind of i knew it was it
had the feeling of being hopeless but
still it kind of like generated ideas
and uh kept me busy
so um but you know while i was working
on it
set these heuristics sas solvers were
getting
really really good so on the one hand
um you know they were kind of that area
that bart had
was one of the early adopters for had
kind of taken off
um and i know people looking back say oh
the 90s was kind of primitive as far as
that solving goes
but there was already some pretty
impressive
results from the heuristic point of view
on the other hand we sort of also were
becoming more and more convinced
that these heuristic methods
uh wouldn't solve the problem in the
worst case because
they're they're the and we're gonna i'm
gonna get back to this later in the talk
hopefully
most of these heuristic methods were
based on resolution proofs
on an unsatisfiable assignment
unsatisfiable formula
they pres produced a resolution proof
not just some kind of certificate but a
certificate of a
form that logicians understood pretty
well
uh called a proof system
uh probably known to most of this
audience
uh called resolutions very simple
and um and we were also getting
the you know the theory area was getting
sharper and sharper
lower bounds on resolution proofs okay
so like being carb potassium sex around
the
the time i'm i'm starting uh
uh thinking about the you know or
continuing thinking about these problems
proved an exponential lower bound for
say random sat formulas
for resolution so we know that these
algorithms
even though they're doing really well on
instances that came from from
applications
had some kind of bottleneck for random
instances
and uh there are many other instances
based on
the proofs of theorems in fact
okay so jack was talking about these
theorems that you can prove hold for
every
um every uh
input you know that there exists some
some kind of object that you can verify
often that verification is very local
you can write down the verification as
some kind of
uh clause and then
uh and then you're like saying
it's unsatisfiable that there's not no
solution
which means that you're sort of like
every possible
solution corresponds to this small set
of small clauses
you take the disjunction sorry the
conjunction over those
no no you know this is this is not an
example this is not a
this is not a witness this is not a
witness this is not a witness and you
take the
the conjunction and you get an
unsatisfiable formula
and so like if you show that that
unsatisfiable formula
has large reputations and saying proving
the theorem
is at least a little bit non-trivial
okay so um and there were lots of these
kind of theorems where the translation
was known to take exponential time
for four sat solvers so
random instances took exponential time
instances that were kind of cleverly
designed take exponential time
so why were these algorithms working so
well
anyway so uh
so fortunately i was very close to
success at designing a better set
algorithm
but unfortunately what that means is
that
the better sad algorithm was being
designed at the office next door to mine
by mohan who i
i'm going to mention my name here uh
pablo pudlock and francis zane and then
uh in follow-up work uh mike sachs
joined them and gotten
even further improvement using similar
techniques
using a sophisticated refinement of the
same techniques
[Music]
and so they they showed that yes you can
beat exhaustive search
but they still only beat it by a
an exponential amount but a an amount
that sort of decreased
with k and still left an exponential
time even for k equals three okay so the
original paper
got a savings over exhaustive search of
2 to the n over k
and then the follow-up got a savings of
something like 2 to the
1.8 and over k
and their their algorithm technique was
simple but their analysis was very nice
okay so the simple you like
do something that's just one step short
of picking a random assignment
you pick a random assignment then as
you're setting it in a random order
as you're setting those literals uh you
see if there's unit propagation
and if there is then you then you don't
randomly set the the variables that are
subject to unit propagation
and they they don't phrase it exactly
this way but i think it's equivalent
okay so um
so at some point i switched gears from
trying to come up with
better set algorithms and said you know
maybe it would be interesting if we
couldn't
design better algorithms if this was
the limit and really i said like the pro
is kind of paradoxical in my thinking uh
maybe just because i'm a you know this
is shows a defect in my mental state
but um but the
more success there was in interesting
approaches to sat
and improvements using interesting new
techniques
uh and for the you know
and all these clever results in the this
this binder that bart had given me and
the more
uh really clever heuristics people were
using
that we knew wouldn't work in the worst
case
the more it seemed like that there was
an inherent barrier
to getting progress in the worst case or
at least possibly
an inherent barrier because
it seemed that over time people were
spending a lot
of intellectual effort trying to get
improved
sad algorithms and yet
the algorithms that we had were still
exponential time
and in fact for k large they weren't
even that much better than exponential
than than brute force search
so um so
what we decided to do is think about
can we quantify you know this question
make precise this question of how much
exactly
how much better can you do than
exhaustive search
and use complexity theory to like
systematically
explore the consequences either
way of whether or not we can do better
so that's what uh that's what
motivated the exponential time
hypothesis and later the strong
exponential time hypothesis
so the
if you look at the the time for
the ppsd algorithm is of the form 2 to
the cn
still and we could define the best
exponential time algorithm as the
infinum
over all the set constant c so that k
sat is in time
2 to the c n and call that result c
k so it's possible that c
k is zero c k exists but it's possible
that c k is zero
meaning you have a strictly sub
exponential time
algorithm or at least like a series of
exponential time algorithms
that improve the exponent are
arbitrarily
so um
so uh so in the constant that you got
from the best algorithms with something
like ck
is at most 1 minus 1.8 over k
so pretty good you know pretty
reasonably small when k is 3 when k is
100
not so small pretty close to one
okay and that was the best that was kind
of like the frontier the best known
value for ck at the time and it's
actually
still for a large enough k is still
pretty much the best note
okay so um
the so what we said well the hypothesis
sort of the whether or not we could
carry out this plan of finding a
sub-exponential algorithm for
sat or whether there's a strict limit is
is really a matter of whether these
constants
are equal to zero or bigger than zero
since then the exponential time
hypothesis is that the constant for
three sat is actually bigger than zero
now if the constant for three sets
bigger than zero then clearly the
constant
for four stat is bigger than zero five
side and so on
we can this this series is going to be
bounded up or bounded by one so it's
going to have a limit
uh the
as far as we know using this formula the
limit could be one
so let's define c infinity to be the
limit of the series of constants
uh and it might be one or it might be
strictly less than one
or it might be zero uh if
the exponential time hypothesis is false
um and please interrupt with questions
uh at any point
okay so uh
so and i said as far as we know
the uh the um
you know the the best constants of
approach one is k
grows so that's the strong exponential
time hypothesis
that that limiting constant is one
so they they get to to
you know it gets as k increases
the algorithmic time requires
get closer and closer to brute force
search
to exhaustive search and uh
vsn williams even give a super strong
exponential time hypothesis
that um
and this is kind of strong it's saying
that that the form
that the uh that the ppse algorithm
took in the savings is really the right
one
it's one month so ck is 1 minus theta
1 in k and this seems like a very daring
hypothesis
but it turns out that a lot
of different set algorithms after ppsc
after and after we started talking about
pth and strong eth all came up with real
again like
really clever approaches to uh
to sat and they all had savings
that were roughly wanting some constant
over k
and they're using like very different
approaches
to doing that so um so
there does seem something like maybe uh
there's something inherent uh at least
like easy algorithms give you savings
one minus one and k
sorry give you constant one minus one
savings wanting 1 and k fraction
and they also in the same paper they
showed
that they introduced this hypothesis
they showed that
it's false for the average case
complexity of satisfaction
okay so what do i mean by formulating
these as hypotheses i'm
being careful not to use the word
conjecture for them
what makes these hypotheses really
interesting
is i think you know if you look like a
conjecture like p
not equal np i'd be kind of surprised if
p
turned out to be equal np okay
if you know until we prove it uh
we could still be wrong but but
complexity theory is sort of like
you know uh if p were equal to np
most of the most of my papers would
become obsolete
okay so i'm really kind of betting my
career the significance of my career
on p not equal np
um so that's kind of like a strong
willing to gamble these hypotheses are
meant to be more
50 50. they could be true or they could
be false
and i don't know which i don't think
anybody
has a really good idea about whether
whether these hypotheses are true or
false so if you ask me that
you know depending on the day if you ask
me to give
odds on the exponential time hypothesis
it's about even odds
strong exponential time hypothesis it
should be
you know it's clearly like uh less
plausible than the exponential time
hypothesis but
not not zero probability either
okay and so what makes them interesting
is that they sort of
like are better uh ways of splitting the
probability space of about complexity
into equal size they could be true they
could be false
categories and they have really
interesting consequences
whether or not they're true or false so
it also bears in mind you can write
papers about
if the exponential time hypothesis holds
then these interesting half things
happen and then you can turn around and
write
papers and say if the exponential time
hypothesis fails
these other interesting things happen
and then you can try like when
you know uh put on your ryan williams
hat and try for a win-win argument
saying well if it holds this happens
and if it fails this happens so this
happens
okay so um
uh so the the uh
exponential time hypothesis so uh
that uh that the complexity of
k sat or threesat is exponential time
is exponential why did i pick threeset
well it turns out that it okay
at the time we said well threesat is
kind of like
hard for this natural class of np
complete problems
uh constrained satisfaction problems so
if you came up
with a three a exponential sub
exponential three set algorithm
it'll turn out that you can come come up
with a
sub exponential k set algorithm for
arbitrarily large k
and then um you can translate that to
showing that
you know you can also solve uh
independent set or colorability or or
lots of other problems in
sub-exponential so it was like
interesting because if the exponential
time of hypothesis were false
for threesat it's also false the
corresponding thing is false for a lot
of different
um np complete problems natural empty
complete problems
so let me try to be more precise about
that
so what do i mean for a sub-exponential
time
algorithm for a an arbitrary
np-complete problem do i mean like sub
exponential in the number of vertices
sub exponential and the number of edges
in this total bit description so we have
to be a little bit careful in saying
what we meant to be sub exponential for
so what we want to do is say is
better by a super polynomial amount than
exhaustive search
so we actually have to define sub
exponential search problems
rather than decision problems and so
within a search problem
you have a bits
to describe what you're searching for
exhaustive search is exponential
in that number of bits times some
polynomial in the input size
and so we said uh let's look at uh
for each problem pi um
look at the smallest constant c
so that there's a 2 to the c n times
some polynomial in the total input size
where capital n algorithm where capital
n is the number of bits to describe a
solution
and so e t h for that problem
is to say that is say that this constant
is bigger than zero
strong eth for that problem is the
constant equals one
or sometimes you know with case that we
want to like take the limit as k goes to
infinity so we have a
sequence of problems we say the limiting
constant for the sequence equals one
okay and uh so this is very similar
distinguishing between the
the size of what you're searching for
and
as one parameter and the size of the
instance as a
different parameter and analyzing the
complexity two-dimensionally
is where in that sense we're following
the parametrized complexity
notion of fellows at all
[Music]
and there are actually lots of of
really deeper connections between
parameterized complexity
and this kind of study of exponential
exact complexities for np complete
problems
so so what we showed in our paper
is that uh first if the if
three sat uh three sat isn't
is you know just a typical instance of a
kind of set
four sat is equivalent five side is
equivalent
uh and so on as far as having uh
exponential time and this was took some
actually to show the equivalence wasn't
completely obvious
uh and i'm gonna talk about that in a
minute okay
and then we showed that that also
implies that
the exponential time hypothesis is true
for many natural np complete problems
okay so uh
actually since then
the dichotomy theorem has been proved
and with all the
the uh building on all the
uh the dichotomy theorem that shows that
every csp
there's kind of a natural
characterization of when a constraint
satisfaction problem
on a final domain is np-complete
building on that
uh johnson logger cavist
and roy showed that um
in fact for any np complete constraint
satisfaction problem
uh the exponential time hypothesis
for that problem is just the same as the
exponential time
for hypothesis sat or whatever other
problem you want so
it's really really a robust notion okay
more than we had thought so if the
exponential time hypothesis is true
not just satisfiability but every np
complete constraint satisfaction problem
requires exponential time and if it's
false
that means that all constraint
satisfaction problems can be solved
faster than exponential time so we could
have picked
uh coloring and it would have worked out
the same we could have picked uh
independence at or clique and it would
have worked out the same
might have been a lot more work to get
there but
uh but in the end
they're all equivalent um
why does it require work to show this
why can't we just plug it into the
standard reductions that we get from
np completeness theorem is because we
really want to be
exponential in the size of the solutions
okay and when you
give a standard np completeness proof
the size of the instances can grow up
polynomially
and so that changes the notion of being
exponential versus sub-exponential
okay but if you look at the standard
reductions between standard problems
they're almost all linear time
reductions
and that's true however it still doesn't
preserve
exponential versus sub-exponential time
in the sense that i was talking about
because usually what linear time means
is linear
in the number of variables plus the
number of constraints
so you have like one gadget that
introduces some new variables for every
original variable
and another kind of gadget that
introduces some new variables
for every kind of constraint
[Music]
and so then
then sub-exponential becomes
sub-exponential and the number of
variables
plus the number of constraints the
number of constraints can be an
arbitrary function
of the number of variables arbitrarily
much larger than the number of variables
so so these don't really preserve
having a even these linear reductions
don't preserve
having a sub-exponential algorithm in
the sense that we're interested
so uh so what we showed
is that uh for satisfiability
you can you can make
the number of constraints a linear
function
of the number of variables without loss
of generality
so precisely we show that
the sparsification lemma uh
and this was improved in in subsequent
work by
uh with calabro
based on a suggestion of mike sax's
so that for every k in epsilon
there exists a constant c so that we can
reduce
k sat in n variables to
k sat on the same number of variables in
a linear number of causes
in time 2 to the epsilon f so the
constant c depends on epsilon and k
originally was doubly exponential in the
improved work
it's exponential
so uh so
then we can now that we've made the
number of constraints or clauses
linear in the number of variables now we
can plug in the standard reductions and
they work just fine
okay so um i'm going to give you like a
quick overview in a minute i'm going to
like show a simpler example that was
actually discovered independently
around the same time for a simpler
problem
uh the independence that problem
um so they showed johnson and zekedys
showed
to how to reduce uh independent set on
an n vertex graph
to independent set on an n vertex graph
with a linear number of edges or
with a multiple n vertex graphs
with each with linear number of edges in
time
mildly exponential 2 to the epsilon n
for an arbitrarily small epsilon
and the idea is to to pick a that
constant c that you're shooting for
sufficiently large
okay the larger we pick c the smaller
the epsilon is going to be
and with this branch if there's a vertex
of degree c
we branch on whether or not to include
it in the independent set this is like
the first algorithm that you think of
maybe the second after exhaustive search
first backtracking algorithm you think
of
for independent set okay so
if there isn't such a vertex you're done
the graph has a linear number of edges
if there is then um you're making lots
of progress
because on one branch you remove one
vertex that's a little bit of progress
on the other branch you eliminate at
least c vertices
that vertex and all its neighbors okay
okay so um so and
you can use this to bound the number of
total number of graphs that you get
in in the whole branching process as n
choose n over c
which as c grows becomes 2 to the
epsilon n for small
small epsilon
for k sat um
we can do a similar thing we you know
that's our proof is doing a similar
thing for k
set there was kind of a mindset barrier
that we had to get through in order to
to come up with this sparsification
technique
or at least for the analysis because i
guess like initially we're thinking
oh what we want to do is make the graph
sparse right
so um so we want to get
you know having more clauses is bad for
us
but what we're really doing in this
argument is saying
if the graph is dense we can use that in
a you know if the graph is
it has a lot of edges that's going to
help us design a faster
independent set algorithm so here you
want to say if we've got lots of
constraints
lots of clauses and especially small
clauses
that's going to help us prune the search
a lot
so it's not that we want to get rid of
clauses
is that we're going to we want to
actually create
small clauses as much as possible
okay so it's not and then utilize those
small
clauses that we create so if the if the
original formula is dense
we want to say we can actually exploit
that
and get faster algorithms while it stays
dense
and it'll be bad when it becomes sparse
but then we're shooting for a reduction
rather than algorithm so we can just say
oh instead of saying that's bad we say
that's also good in a different way
okay so um so our goal is actually to
create
many small clauses as many as possible
and here's how we'll do that for
threesat uh
we'll have uh three levels of of
branching rules
okay one is the the
if so first we always remove clauses if
one clause contains another cause we
remove the larger costs
because it's kind of redundant so that's
that's an obvious scent
okay so as we're creating clauses if
they subsume
other clauses we remove the remove the
the subsumed clauses
so um so if we've got a lot of really
small clauses
two clause you know if you've got lots
of one clauses those are just variables
we're already done if we've got lots of
two clauses
then um they have to like
some a lot of those two clauses have to
contain the same variable
branch on that variable and that's
creating a law
of of one clauses setting variables
uh you know and that's
immediately good okay so
if we have a a lot of two clauses
containing the same variable
we branch on that variable in the true
case we just get that one variable
in the false case we actually get more
because every
variable that appears within a clause
now now has a
defined truth value okay
uh if there aren't a lot of two clauses
then we look at the three clauses
and um the best thing is if we
uh have a three clause that contains
a lot of three clauses that contain a
pair of variables x or y
okay um so if they do
contain a lot of these literals we're
going to branch on not
is x true is y true we're going to
branch on whether is
x or y true and in this case
in the true case we just get one two
clause
okay but in the false case we get a
whole bunch of variables
um so like the true case it doesn't seem
like we're making progress at all
until we think that we really want to
introduce small clauses and two clauses
are pretty
good at that okay and uh
so then the the the fallback is if there
are
many three clauses that contain one
variable
but there aren't a lot of three clauses
that contain any pair of variables
then we branch on that one variable in
one case we get one variable
and in the other case we get a whole
bunch of two clauses
lead to the better kinds of branching in
the future
um i'm not seeing any
you know please stop me and ask
questions
although i need to
so um so then the the
argument is very similar you know for
the time analysis it's very similar
to the johnson's equity analysis except
we have to like
analyze the the effects of these rules
separately
um rule one that's very similar to the
johnson's negative
because whenever we get um
we either get one variable or a whole
bunch of variables
okay um
actually i think i skipped over so so we
can say like
the number of false branches for rule
ones
or rule twos both of those create a
whole bunch of variables
and we can create at most n variables
total so that bounds the number of false
branches
for rules one or rules two it also
bounds at least marginally the number of
crew branches for rule three
then whenever we
get too many two clauses where we
guaranteed
to be able to apply rule one so
um so we'll we'll make sure that
that no variable ever appears in too
many two clauses
and this is going to bound the number of
two clauses that we could ever create
because if we create too many
then we'll use rule one a lot and then
rule one will will set all the variables
along most paths and that's going to
bound the number
of true branches for rule 2 and false
branches for rule 3.
so when you put all these things
together you can show that
the total number of branches until we
run out of rules to apply
and the formula is sparse is going to be
just mildly exponential
okay okay and so
you can generalize that to k set instead
of three rules we'll have roughly k
choose two rules
uh based on the on the size of clauses
up to k and uh the sizes of the
of the sets of variables that we're
gonna branch on
okay uh and from when you sparsify
uh so if you like combine all these
things
uh this is not only true for sat that we
can do specification
we can do sparsification for any kind of
np complete constraint satisfaction
problem
because when you take any
np any constraint satisfaction problem
it's really easy to map
at the case at we can specify the k-stat
instance that we get
and then use the reductions that we get
from the dichotomy theorem that are just
linear in the number of variables and
plus constraints
to map it back to an instance
of the original problem pi and that's
going to have both a linear number of
variables
and a linear number of constraints
so so we can take
any constraint satisfaction problem and
uh reduce it to the same constraint
satisfaction problem
with a linear number of constraints in
the number of variables
okay and so that that really uh is kind
of like an intuitive
uh is a heart not intuitive way of
proving something intuitive
which is that if this exponential time
hypothesis is true
what it says is that the hard instances
of a constraint satisfaction problem
are those with a linear number of
constraints
okay um and you know if you look at
at instances with with
more than a linear you know more than
proportional number of constraints to
variables
those tend to be very over constrained
and called over constrained instances
and become easier and especially for
like random instances seem to be
of csps are our hardest at the
there's going to be a for each csp a
fixed constant density
uh threshold where it goes from
satisfiable to unsatisfiable where it
becomes the hardest
on the other hand we can also
show that eth implies that the
hard instances are not too sparse
they're also not going to be under
constrained instances
so uh what we
what we show is like look at sat with no
bound on k
um but where we're seeing the number of
constraints is at most d
times n we were able to give
a uh use filler's
[Music]
method to to give a
an improved algorithm for any fixed d
but we also showed that as d increases
the the constants that you get are the
same as the constants you get
in the limit for k set so um
so exponential time hypothesis for k
sat imply is equivalent to the
exponential time hypothesis
for a linear number of constraints that
but also for strong the strong versions
of these the limiting
constant for one is one if and only if
the limiting constant for the other is
one
uh and it also follows from this
that uh okay with a little bit of work
that that means that
um the densest instance the the hard
instances for k sat
must have a density that's an increasing
function
with k okay
uh now i think we get like that the hard
instances for k set must be at least
like linear in density or polynomial in
density
density must be polynomial in k really
intuitively it should be exponential in
k
so i i would challenge you to like think
about reasons why
that density must grow exponentially and
i'm really far behind
okay so another consequences
uh in the that we of the exponential
time hypothesis
is very intuitive say okay
uh we wanted to say that np complete
problems are not all equivalent
quantitatively these notions of the
constants for each problem
give us a way of formalizing that we
were able to show that the constant
for k sat is less than the limiting
constant by a 1 minus
omega 1 and k factor and it follows then
that if the exponential time i bought
you know they could all be zero
but if they're not all zero that means
that they're
these constants c k are strictly
increasing
infinitely often and so that
is a formalization of the intuition that
k sap becomes harder
as k increases
okay so what i what i'd like people to
work one thing i'd love
to happen is you know we should sort of
in the limit
in case that becomes harder but we don't
have like a bound that says that
that each k k plus one side is harder
strictly harder than k sub
um another thing uh that
follows from eth it's not just the
hardness of
of um satisfied worst case
satisfiability but even some very
special cases of satisfiability
become exponential uh are going to be
exponentially hard
like uh unique satisfiability so even
if you're given a promise that there's
at most one satisfying assignment
finding that satisfying assignment is
going to be exponentially hard
and in fact it's going to be in the
limit
equally hard as the the constant for
uh the exact exponent for unique case at
is equal
to the constant for the general case so
that shows that
we can't really use uh say that we're
going to get sub-exponential time
algorithms based on
the structure of the set the solution
space because
i think unique solution is the simplest
non-degenerate solution space
that you could think of
so so we could say well how about
instances can we come up with better
algorithms
you know when we have restrictions on
the instances that imply that there are
better algorithms are we going to be
able to further improve
these algorithms a lot of people have
put it
have really nice results saying no um
like looks enough marks and answer up
show that if
the strong exponential time hypothesis
is true you can't
uh you know if we have a bounded tree
with graph a bound on the tree width of
the graph
then you can usually solve problems in
exponential time in the tree with
and what this says is that you're not
going to do much better than that
for bounded tree with graphs
we also have a a lot of
ways of of taking uh
complexity results about np-complete
problems
and showing uh using them to show
hardness
of problems that are in polynomial time
okay and this kind of adds to a growing
area
that we'll call fine grain complexity
we made up that name for simon's program
a few years ago
um so uh and
you can say like other strands involved
like hardness based on the k-some
conjecture introduced by uh
gajantum and over mars in the context of
computational geometry
and work by vasileska williams and
williams
on uh equivalence of many triangle
problems
uh and so like these different
basic heart problems uh the ex versions
of the exponential time hypothesis kind
of joined together
with some of these other lines of work
converge into an
area that's that's really exciting
because it's
giving um showing that
lots of the textbook algorithms
just can't uh either can't be improved
or if they could if one could be
improved that would have
ripple effects into lots of the others
into these kind of basic core
algorithmic challenges
so um so in
fine grained complexity kind of uh
you're
looking at generic you know reductions
between uh
between problems that uh
preserve almost exactly the the time
that the
the best time that no known for the
algorithms
for algorithms between the problems and
i'm going to like really slide over this
quickly because i don't
have only five minutes left so i'm just
going to give one quick example
that relates eth
to this k sum conjecture this is an
example due to precost q and williams
that shows that if the exponential time
hypothesis is true
the k sum problem is like given
k sets of n numbers is there a
one number from each set that sums to a
given target
um and what they show this is basically
a scaled
rescale you can rescale the sub
np complete subset sum problem to
be an exponential size instance
of the the k sum problem
and so it follows from this rescaling
that if the exponential time hypothesis
is true
then the k sum requires n to the
omega k time okay
now the conjecture is much this k sum
conjecture
is much stronger that it requires
exactly n to the k over two time
but n to the omega k has a lot a number
of the same
same consequences that the strong
conjecture would have
okay just a little bit weaker um
so uh so the and the idea
is uh we can use these kind of standard
reductions using sparsification and the
standard technique
to show that under eta subsystem
requires exponential time
and then do this split and list
reduction from subset sum
to a mildly exponential 2 to the n over
k
size instance of the k sum problem and
then a better than
degree k algorithm for k sum
much better than degree k when combined
with this would give us a 2 to the
little o of n algorithm
for the subset sum problem and hence for
satisfiability
okay so um so that was like one of the
starting points of this kind of merger
of these different strands into
fine-grained complexity
since then there has been so many
textbook problems that based on some of
these
a small number of conjectures uh the
complexity would be
exactly classified okay
so uh so as i said these are i should
say
they're they're hypotheses rather than
conjectures not sure that they're true
but they show a common algorithmic
challenge that
underlies progress on a whole bunch of
seemingly unrelated
algorithmic problems and uh
i'll say single out uh virginia vessels
williams as like kind of the leading
researcher
in this area but there are so many other
people
doing uh exciting work that i don't have
time to mention
okay and i was going to talk about
my own work but just uh
there's this problem orthogonal vectors
that many of the
sad hardness results go through and then
you get like
hardness for all sorts of natural
probably you open up your algorithms
textbook
you look at especially under under
dynamic programming a lot of the
algorithms that you see
have been shown that if you could
improve them
you would actually improve the sad
algorithms
and refute either the exponential time
hypothesis
or strongly exponential time hypothesis
okay so if these hypotheses are true
then we get a really detailed picture
of the complexity both of hard problems
and of problems within p
and we get a lot of insight into the
kind of structure of instances
that are likely to be the hardest
problems for for uh
for satisfiability if the conjectures
are false
well like if the exponential time like
hypothesis is false
what we said is we get sub-exponential
algorithms not just for sat
but for all csp problems and and
the scope goes on beyond that
so a lot of the np-complete problems
would just become
all simultaneously sub-exponential if
strong eth is false
i don't have a lot of algorithmic
consequences for that
so i'd be interested in people coming up
with algorithmic consequences if
if strong eth is false a lot of
consequences if it's true
um however another interesting
indirect consequence is that if these
are false we get
um improvements in circuit lower bounds
and this builds on the connection of by
ryan williams
between circuit sat and circuit
and lower bounds for circuits
so uh one statement
of this type of result is by jahanju
miles and viola they say if the
exponential time hypothesis is false
there's a function in
e to the np that requires super linear
size circuits
proving a super linear size lower bound
for circuits
is a major challenge in complexity
theory
if the strong eth is false it's a little
bit weaker you only get a linear bound
for series parallel
super linear bound for series parallel
circuits okay
it would be nice to put these lower
bounds in a smaller complexity class e
to the np
is still a little bit high up there for
my taste
okay well
um why should anyone even think that
exponential time hypothesis and strong
exponential time hypothesis
are even possible um
because we have these stat solvers that
are solving instances with millions of
ex
you know really quickly on instances a
sat with millions of examples you know
how could anyone argue with a straight
face that's that is really hard
and what i want to say is these
hypotheses are about the worst case time
for sat and the the results
the heuristic results are really about
typical instances that come up
in certain applications and they don't
actually generalize even to instances
that come up in other applications
all the time it's not always easy to map
your uh application to a kind of sat
that's easy to solve for these
with these solvers as an are
representing your
your instance as a sat problem it's an
art in itself
okay and i'm sure lots of people here
know that
so well and our math will do better
so and uh average case since complexity
of sad is also
really different from the worst case
complexity
okay so and as i said we can make this
precise by looking at
resolution proofs because
most of the current even the current
generation of sas solvers
can be simulated on unsatisfied instance
by
uh resolution proofs where the size of
the proofs is roughly the same as the
time
that or a lower bound on the time that
the sas solvers will take
so um so can we
show that exponential time hypothesis
and strong exponential time hypotheses
are true for these kind of resolution
proofs uh
pablo pudlock uh with some prompting
from me
uh show that this is true that even the
strong exponential time hypothesis
is true for tree-like resolution proofs
that was like generation one of sat
solvers
chris beck and i show that a similar
thing
for regular resolution proofs and
unfortunately you know that might have
been
okay as a lower bound strong eth for
generation two of sas solvers but
generation three using like clause
learning
uh already goes beyond regular
resolution
and uh and so we'd really love to have a
similar result
for general resolution lower balance the
best lower bound
we i know of for general resolution
is uh in the same paper uh
with a lower bound of 1.5 to
something approaching one as k gross
shows like the exponential time
hypothesis is true
and gets pretty close but um
we have a gap between uh between
exponential time by positive strong
uh yes it was a question uh the question
is with regard to alpha what is alpha in
there
okay so alpha in our proof i think it's
like an eighth or something
it's not it is a little bit different in
the three results
but it's just like some fixed number
can i ask a follow-up yeah um
so i was interested in whether
eth or you know
strong eth can be used as a way to
rule out certain parameters as
explanatory of the power of cdcl sat
solvers
and i saw an earlier result you had
where it was shown that even if
i don't quite recall the result but
this is the marks
and one other person result
yeah so uh and the one i stated was for
independence that
but they have very similar results for
for variants of staff
and so that would conclusively show that
certain kind of quote-unquote natural
parameters
may not be good candidates to explain
the power of cdco
right so uh and i you know so again
um you know this is complex
you know making the assumption that you
know they say that you can't improve
those
uh you can't improve the running time in
terms of those parameters
uh as um
without improving the the running time
in general
um that doesn't mean absolutely that
these sat solvers haven't done that
so uh so maybe something that we should
try to work on is to show
that is to try to show a proof
complexity lower bound
for instances with bounded tree width
yeah i think that would be a really
interesting result
so can we show uh that
you know here's an instance with tree
with you know
for any tree with we can like come up
with an instance of that specified tree
width
where uh where the smallest resolution
proof
is exponential in that free width right
i don't think anyone's done anything
similar correct me if i'm wrong
if they if there's someone who's done
something similar they're probably in
this meeting
so please please chime in
okay and uh so saying like
the value of hypotheses hypotheses isn't
because
i believe that they're true is because
they
summarize the state of the art on
important problems
sort of like give a distinction between
incremental progress
and fundamental progress
on the different problems the unify
progress
on a wide variety of algorithmic
problems that you wouldn't think are
connected
and identify common challenges in coming
up with algorithms for these different
problems
they link complexity theory and
algorithm design
and allow really precise statements
about
uh can we formalize our intuitions about
what makes
instances and and problems easier or
hard
i apologize for going over a bit
thank you for the talk so uh
clap on behalf of everybody and uh so
let's uh
let's open the floor for questions um
there's nothing in the chat
or the q a so either speak up or type
something in
um so i have a comment
yeah yeah go ahead yeah
so we recently used strong eth to show
that
a reduction from the theory of equality
and uninterpreted function symbols
to sat can
the best you can do is n log n so the
theory of equality and uninterpreted
function symbols is just
pointing for free that is uh it's just
you know functions
and constants and equalities between
them right so you can use this in
verification for many many
settings and the way you usually solve
such formulas is
by doing an ackermann style reduction to
to sat
uh oh that's one way to do it there are
other ways
and um you show
we show that you cannot do anything
better than n log n
on if if strongly change is true
so i just wanted to let you know uh did
that sound
so example yeah so um
i can send you the paper offline uh
please do
um so i may
may have some related work for similar
problems within polynomial time
we're looking at like the complexity of
first order problems
where you have like equality between
variables
yeah so um
and also um with with uh with marvin
uh kunamina and a bunch of of you ucsd
students i'm also
been looking at the complexity of uh
of logics where you have uh inequality
total orders uh between
variables and relating those to
to uh to satisfy ability and strong
information
uh i'm a little bit impressed with your
result because you're
you're somehow getting an assumption
about sap being
hard and getting that to be a barrier to
reducing
to sat rather than reducing from sat
all right counter-intuitive how you do
that
so i'm interested yeah now i'll send the
paper
there's a comment oh sorry go ahead
russell this would give
a really good reduction from sat to
itself
no i think we use this draxler paper
which has a let me let me
i'll have to now remind myself of this
anyway
um please send me the paper or maybe uh
if since other people might be
interested you could also put a link
in the chat yeah if you haven't already
yeah i will see there's one thing in the
chat
yeah stephen cider has a comment in the
chat um
uh we know that unsatisfiable formulas
have resolution proofs that is
of size that is fpt and the tree width
of the primal
graph but the question is open for the
tree width of the instance graph
right so saying that there might not be
i was asking for a lower bound in terms
of the tree width
so first which graph we're talking about
is a little bit ambiguous um
so we can ask the same question or
different kinds of related graphs to the
to the
to the instance um and
uh i was asking for a lower bound so
it's interesting to start
first by saying is there an upper bound
uh that that matches the best algorithms
can the best algorithms for the
restricted tree with case
actually be stimulated by equivalent
size
resolution proofs is that
what you're hinting at seven
um yes i yes i think that's
that's correct uh so it's it's
a little bit uh clear i think for this
the primal graph where we have
the variables are the vertices and you
have an edge whenever
two variables appear together in a
clause that's this very
basic graph model um there it's easy
that
to transform any algorithm that solves
the sub
problem on this instance that it can
also output
a resolution proof as a witness that's
relatively easy
but if you now look at the incidence
graph which is this fiber type graph
between variables and
clauses then the question is so
we don't know whether even
such instances have resolution proofs
that are fbt in the size uh
fbt in the tributes of this incidence
graph not
speaking about an algorithm that
actually finds
the proof
uh russell i posted the paper and the
link to a talk pant and then on this one
great thank you so albert has a question
so maybe you want to just
say your question
yeah so my question is whether eth has
anything to say about the permanent
of any matrices yeah so
um so
uh there's a similar
uh sort of exact complexity
of counting problems and there are lots
of really nice
uh connection connections
so i was looking at this a while ago and
i don't remember
who exactly did what in this area but
there is actually a very well developed
um uh kind of
analog of eth or counting problems
including the permanent and uh
and there may be like a
uh we may from from eth hardness
there may be a loss of a login
in the exponent i'm not sure so it might
be
that you you eth implies that you can't
compute it
in time two to the little o of n over
log n
so there's there's like the if you look
at the
the you know i said everything is kind
of like linear
uh but if you look at the reduction
from sat to permanent
that's the standard proof of you know
from counting sat
to permanent that's the standard proof
of sharpie
completeness is not actually linear time
but then uh there are some
very clever roundabout methods
to get better better lower bounds on
better conditional lower bounds on
computing the
or permanent could even use sub
exponential reductions
um so the the ones i know
use use techniques like polynomial
interpolation
rather than sub exponential reduction is
they're using uh using
map you know turing reductions rather
than mapping reductions
to get sharper valves but uh
it's been a couple of years since i read
these papers and so
uh i'm i'm not remembering the details
there's another question in the chat
window from uh from ice rubik
asking is there an analog for k
quantifier qbf
yeah eg that you need yeah go ahead yeah
so
um so uh ryan and rahul santana
i think like had the first papers on
the analogs of exponential time
hypothesis for
for k quantifier qbf for strong
exponential time hypothesis
if you've got like quantifiers
so so the thing is a lot of the
improvements that you get for k
quantifier qbf if the number
if the you know you you would like
intuitively think the hard cases
are where you have like an existential
n over two variables followed by a
universal and over two variables
followed by the inside of the formula
so
but actually if you think about that for
a second
you can do exhaustive search over the
outside variables and then you've
reduced to a sat problem
on n over two variables and so whatever
savings you get for sat
you can kind of translate to this kind
of balance case
and so the trickiest cases involve like
quantifier structures that are not at
all balanced
um and trying to reason about those
and it does get constant it got to it
does it complicate it
i had some work with chris calabro
and mohan and then there was his paper
by ryan
and rahul um and
again uh even even even the results in
our paper i don't quite remember at this
time
so maybe ryan could save me and tell me
what the state of the art is here
so paul commented on this the state of
the art of what exactly sorry i was
awake
uh the exponential time
uh uh conjecture of
a quantified boolean uh
truth of quantified boolean formulas oh
right so um
so there there is like a you know for
all exists
version of um seth
um if seth is false
then um this is false
as you increase more and more
quantifiers the problem actually gets
easier the more
the more alternations you got the the
faster
the algorithms known can run so it's
fairly counterintuitive um from that
perspective
i mean that's more or less of a summary
but
yeah um
so so paul had a follow-up comment too
okay so i think i think this is a
different
comment yeah okay but i'm still trying
to parse it
so paul could you just explain your
comment
uh
okay uh
okay so paul's having trouble on muting
so i will try to
read it and try to understand it okay
so uh
so i guess uh okay so yeah so
um so the one exam
some examples where we're able to show
that the limiting constants
are are kind of identical
for for strong eth the standard strong
eth
in variance is we're able to show that
for the unique sad case that that you
get the same constant
and for the the uh
the um
the bounded density case okay yeah so
uh there's
uh
so that the paper okay so um
so i should say there is a paper
there there aren't so many uh
so many results that said you know we
would want
results to say uh if the strong eth
hypothesis is true then the
constant for independent set is exactly
this number
the constant for this problem is exactly
this other number
and so on so you know it would be great
to have some kind of
version uh you know exponential time
analog of the unique games conjecture
where if you assume uh that conjecture
all these other constants actually are
kind of mathematically well defined
and you know exactly what you're
shooting for
we don't have that there's a paper by a
very
large number of authors including daniel
luxtranoff and mohan patturi
and i'm forgetting exactly who else that
gives that does give for some examples
that strong eth would imply that certain
problems had constant one
so um
so but i i'm not remembering the exact
the exact link um so
uh uh
the paper that civil uh points to
i think is like one in a series but i'm
not sure whether
it is the is the first link in the
series
as a book chapter it's probably further
along
and maybe combine several conference
papers
would be my guess
all right so thank you again russell we
there's another talk in
about seven minutes so we probably need
to wrap things up i believe there's a
fellows talk in seven minutes so
thank you again russell and thank you on
behalf of everyone else
uh clap and um and and thank you also
jack so uh it's a very nice session
so uh so i guess that there's some
chance to go to gather town i think i
don't know what the link though but if
people want to continue talking
afterwards
maybe someone will post a gather town
link or you guys know how to go
so otherwise i think we're done
thanks thanks